[Music]
hey guys it's inca welcome back to
training vs traditional where i will be
making trendy interpretations of your
favorite classics unfortunately my
previous co-host
chris lovingly known as big forehead
will
no longer be able to join us but that's
okay he'll be right here watching over
us i have found an amazingly talented
roster of friends to come and join me on
this journey beginning with alvin
i'm alvin i'm one of the producers on
tasty and i make food and what are we
making today today we are making
cheesecake
i
love cheesecake i don't eat it as often
because it's so rich and heavy but i
love how creamy it is it's a lot of
calories that i don't want to know i'm
putting in my stomach but it's really
good the cheesing i'm doing today will
be a little bit different i kind of have
a slight hunch on what you might be
making you're excited i'm very excited
i'm excited i'm excited to eat yours i'm
excited to go on a
actual showdown with alvin and
competition all right so we're gonna get
started okay alvin thank you you're
going first good luck yep i'll see you
later thanks i'm not gonna need it
you're gonna win
you're what i think when you like look
up or think of the word cheesecake the
first thing that people think of is like
new york style cheesecake it's a thick
slice nice graham cracker crust i'm
gonna be taking inspiration from that
but adding a couple of twists because
that's how i like to make my cheesecake
first thing
the crust graham crackers
sometimes you gotta beat it down i like
adding brown sugar because this tastes
better than regular sugar a little bit
of salt
lock this down
away we go so
today i am actually going to be making
the jiggly cheesecake from japan i feel
like it is the first thing that pops to
mind when people think trendy cheesecake
i've had it when i was in osaka i think
i waited in line for like an hour before
i got my cake it's really the texture
that won me over soft almost like
souffle-like very jiggly that's what i'm
going to try and aim for today starting
with
some cake pans you actually bake it in a
water bath which just means i'm going to
be filling up this pan with a little bit
of water
and then
we're going to bake it like so it allows
there to be more moisture when you're
baking it in the oven and it's really
important if you don't want your
cheesecake to crack and for this one you
really really really do want that smooth
top i am going to fill this with water
now and pop it in the oven okay so the
texture i like to look for is pretty
fine there's no huge lumps in there this
is melted butter makes it come all
together it's looking like wet sand oh
it smells good though springform pan
dump this all in
squishing it down with a measuring cup
because it's really satisfying i like
graham crackers you actually know it's
invented to not taste good someone could
look this up but somehow everybody used
it for like the best tasting things
that's smooth i'm gonna go bake this now
i'm gonna start off by actually melting
down a couple of things we have a little
bit of cream cheese then we're going to
put in some butter butter is always good
a little bit of milk whole milk for
desserts the more fat the better right
now it's super lumpy very chunky we just
want to melt it down until it's all
together you don't want it to boil i'm
actually going to leave this to a side
and get cracking
many eggs we're just going to separate
the egg whites from the egg yolks these
eggs are the only thing that are going
to give our cheesecake volume so
don't want to mess that up this is
a lot of cream cheese it's
it's a lot i use more than a lot of
people might say i softened this by
putting it in the microwave add my sugar
it saves a lot of our muscles sugar
and cream cheese all coming together no
problems no lumps you don't have to be
this violent but you know i just want my
stuff to come out faster i'm actually
kind of getting all the sides you
remember how i said how this is supposed
to save you arm muscle and tiredness
i just realized i'm getting pretty tired
right now i think it's worth it check
back in like five minutes
i might have a different answer for you
guys hello
cream cheese and butter smells like
yogurt like hot yogurt some people says
this looks like mayo
i think it looks like delicious
cheesecake it looks like alfredo sauce
right now looking good looking good you
guys see how it's now this like goopy
texture take it off of the heat we want
to temper the eggs a little bit you
don't want to cook the eggs we're going
to add
the cream slowly instantly makes it a
lot lighter and paler in color looks
great i just want to combine this well
now it just looks like a custard
cheesecake in general is just a lot of
mixing
i'm tired it's like nice smooth almost
like
like a sticky pudding kind of thing
we're gonna stop because i almost
spilled the next ones are the wet
ingredients first we do vanilla oh that
definitely smells better
wow it's getting warm the eggs
we're slowly getting there
my hand is getting tired
[Music]
nice
i like to make it a little bit lighter
so i'm going to add a little bit of sour
cream you can just eat more of it which
is what i like to do a lot of blending
happening today i want to put in some
matcha i feel like matcha is a really
really popular flavor now i also love
matcha a lot and so matcha jiggly
cheesecake
can't get any trendier than that right
i'm going to start off by sifting in
cake flour
helpful you makes the process a little
more fun get all the cornstarch in the
reason i'm sifting it is just because i
also don't want like lumps of flour in
there now we're just combining all of it
together the matcha smells so good i
love matcha basically if there's a
matcha anything
i will buy it everything is well
combined together as one
this is pretty much done
much better probably eat this right now
if you wanted but it's probably not a
good idea this is the crust it's been
cooling it smells really good there's
some bubbles and potentially some small
lumps and that's okay because we're
going to solve all these problems with a
sieve may i have some help with the
sieve please
thank you man i wish life was this easy
to get all this stuff in here i shall
take it from here i don't like lumps in
my cheesecake i don't think anybody does
i made any mistakes while making it
i just do this most important thing is
that it's
silky smooth so better to be safe than
sorry you know that is pretty much it
more for me
there might be some more bubbles so
we're just gonna
okay we're gonna bake this so now we
move on to making the meringue mixture i
have my egg whites here and some sugar
we just want to make this fluffy this is
also the most time consuming part you
gotta do it
where are we at
soft peak stage beautiful egg whites i'm
just going to add a little bit in first
make sure they're
integrated you can feel
the air we can start folding in the
meringue mixture gotta be gentle putting
the rest of it in i think it's looking
pretty good i think we're there don't
mess with it anymore then you have to
this
is okay i got some parchment paper
we're just lining the bottom the heavy
bowl
yay
tapping the bubbles out
so make sure
smooth out need to put this in the oven
asap
be right back we have four different
cooking temperatures and four different
cooking times we're gonna start with low
heat go up to high heat go back to low
heat and then go finish off with high
heat because low heat can cook it
without making it crack on top and then
high heat will help it rise and give it
color hopefully next time when you guys
see me
i have
a cake that has fully risen and is not
undercooked the cheesecake has been in
for a while it's pretty much fully
cooked smooth no cracks the last step i
like to do is a little sour cream
topping sour cream sugar and a little
bit of vanilla put it all together a lot
of creamy stuff today sounds like mac
and cheese again it's basically like
putting another cheesecake on cheesecake
my favorite part is when you put it on
look at this
look at that look at those ribbons what
happens to the michelin man when he
retires and this looks like it's going
pretty well we're gonna put this back in
the oven literally for like five minutes
and then after that it's gonna take a
nap in the fridge good thing i made one
yesterday i also made a strawberry
topping because i like strawberries and
cheesecake so very excited to eat this
gotta be careful though
okay
the cake
is done it looks like this right now we
just need to be like be really quick if
i do a little tap tap it comes off
easily
i'm like panicking basically what i'm
gonna try and do is flip it over
my history of flipping things isn't very
good
okay we flipped it smells good i'm gonna
peel this layer off
[Music]
now for flip number two i'm really
nervous the last time i tried to do it
it fell off so i don't trust myself what
i do what i do what i do what i do what
i do
here
okay
it's very soft
it's pretty good
pat pat tap tap jiggle jiggle wobble
wobble wibble it passed the jiggle test
so i think we're good now we're gonna
move on to final plating
yay
[Music]
okay alvin you ready i am ready
[Music]
yours is a green pillow i would gladly
sleep on you cheat and buy this from the
store this
looks like the gourmet stuff you get at
like cheesecake factories nice work
nice we have our special guest who loves
cheesecakes who's gonna come in and tell
us which one they like more this is
catching my attention this is very red
this is giving me the typical new york
cheesecake this is super gorgeous it
looks very fluffy
oh this is quick
this is thick look at the presentation
oh my goodness this is pretty pretty
nervous let's get all of it in one bite
wow
wow that's very good my parents being
from brooklyn had high standards for
their cheesecakes and this consistency
is very on par you did that alvin thank
you thank you now for the pillow
oh it's really good it is so moist you
can really taste the matcha they're so
happy this one's real good your nails
are matching as well look at this it was
meant to be we both did really good oh
man two very good takes on cheesecake
this is hard i can't ignore my stomach
the matcha cheesecake wins i love it
it's so good i love the fresh take on it
it was the nails wasn't it shake this
thank you bye bye congratulations
yeah well done
this is the biggest achievement of 2020.
i'm so emotional right now
i was fully expecting to lose
congratulations thank you thank you
do this smell so good
this is very good very very good thanks
so much for joining me alvin thank you
for having me that's it for today thank
you guys for watching let me know what
you want to see on 21st traditional what
kind of food leave a comment below
otherwise
see you next time bye
[Music]
you